[Musique]
il ya 230 ans dans cette même salle les
députés du tiers état ont fait le
serment de ne pas se séparer avant
l'élaboration de la toute première
constitution française
pour cette deuxième édition de la nuit
du droit à l'université versailles saint
quentin a décidé de mettre à l'honneur
un texte fondateur
la déclaration des droits de l'homme et
du citoyen de 1789 on a tous
l'impression connaître la déclaration à
grenoble et du citoyen et finalement on
se rend compte que en le lisant le
relisant il est assez mystérieux j'ai
envie de dire même que tous les juristes
ne connaissent pas si bien que ça et
nous nous avons choisi deux
de travailler sur ce texte et de le
présenter au public pour mieux le faire
connaître
trois étudiants ont travaillé durant
plusieurs semaines pour déclamer ce
fameux texte face au public
vous le retrouvez dans cette salle pour
cet événement est de pouvoir d'éclat
mais ici ça a vraiment du sens pour moi
et c'est une grande chance ça représente
un texte fondateur qui qui est
nécessaire en fait toujours de revenir à
ce texte
il donne des droits aux citoyens et
c'est vraiment la figure même du citoyen
français
la soirée s'est poursuivie avec des
conférences des débats en deux actes
autour de la déclaration
cette dimension de transmission de la
mémoire et des valeurs est tout à fait
essentiel est la présence de jeunes en
est un symbole donc tu m'aides intermède
musical la nuit du droit à la salle du
jeu de paume affiché complet
[Musique]